I like everyone - close your eyes now
bring to mind a picture of a computer
engineer maybe typing away at a terminal
all right you got it okay now open them
I'm betting that what you thought of
probably did it look like this now it's
true I'm past the age of playing with
dolls but when I saw that Mattel had
created computer engineer Barbie I got
super excited I mean how cool is it that
there is a mainstream toy telling young
girls that they can be successful in the
field of computing I mean it even came
with a super cool book that was talking
about how Barbie is creating a game to
teach kids to play with computers except
when Barbie's sister asked her if she
can play the game Barbies responds oh no
I'm just designing the game
I'll need Stephan and Brian to help me
build it what you're telling me the
computer engineer Barbie can't even code
I was top of that she needs the guys to
save the day a second time when her
computer gets a virus and crashes my
feeling of excitement became horked it's
true women are choosing not to study
computer science but that choice it's
not made in a vacuum it's a choice
constrained by the reality of the world
they live in a world that tells them
from a young age they do not belong some
of those signals can be overt like the
case of Barbies laughable computer
engineering career but some of them can
be more subtle like the case of Alana
King a black female computer science
major every time she went to the
Stanford CS building she would get asked
hey are you lost until finally she got
so fed up with it that she wrote a blog
post no I'm not lost what about the case
of Isis winger when she was featured on
a recruiting poster for her company
software engineering team the ad blew up
with comments but with people saying she
must be a hired model and not an actual
engineer these stereotypes surrounding
us since birth kind of powerful effects
no matter how hard our conscious minds
seek to reject them Stanford
psychologist Claude Steele coined the
term stereotype threat to describe a
situation in which an individual feels
at risk of conforming to a stereotype in
his experiment when African Americans
were asked to identify their race before
taking an aptitude test they perform
more poorly than white students however
if you remove this race question all of
a sudden that difference all that
disappears and these findings have been
replicated many times since in a test of
sports abilities white men perform more
poorly than black men however
you frame it as a test of sports
intelligence all of a sudden that Delta
flips if you remind even women of their
Asian Asst before they take a math test
they'll do better remind them of their
sex and they'll do worse I haven't heard
about any of this research before I
started my first job as a computer
engineer but if you had asked me what
effect I thought stereotypes around
women in engineering could have on me I
would have said none I graduated first
in my class I had several job offers and
I actually liked nerd culture I mean I
build robots for a hobby I tell dorky
Star Wars jokes even though I'm the only
one that ever lasted them and even
though I was in the minority on my team
I felt welcome so the first day I
started until about a year into my job I
I hit a wall it was an assignment I just
could not figure out and with each
failed attempt to crack it I felt a
little more of my confidence drain away
until suddenly I found myself thinking
the unthinkable maybe I wasn't meant to
be an engineer I thought about quitting
every day I didn't realize it at the
time but that right there was the power
of stereotype it turned which should
have been a tiny step back into proof
that every stereotype I'd internalized
over my whole life was correct I wasn't
good enough I didn't belong I knew that
I had to ask for help and I knew it
shouldn't be a big deal I mean my team
was super collaborative but I couldn't
bring myself to do it for me asking for
help
it meant becoming like Barbies it meant
admitting I'd failed and I wouldn't just
be failing myself I'd be failing women
everywhere as one of the few of us I
stood for all of us so I couldn't just
be good I had to be exceptional so that
maybe I could disprove the stereotype
that women didn't belong in engineering
try taking that weight on your shoulders
as a 22 year old I've read research by
Carnegie Mellon at Carnegie Mellon with
students there and the experiences
reported by women were eerily similar to
my own many came in a stellar math and
science students but as they ran into
challenges with their introductory
programming courses they too began to
believe the voices they'd once rejected
voices that told them they'd only been
admitted because they were women it
didn't matter that they eventually
mastered the material they couldn't get
it out of their heads of the women
interviewed half would drop out of the
program but of those dropouts half were
on the honor roll these women aren't the
only one paying the cops here businesses
are missing out two companies that have
more gender diversity have greater
profits and greater sales revenue than
their competitors
studies show that teams that include
women are more innovative and more
productive than those that don't
so if we want to improve our business
outcomes keep women from dropping out of
these programs let's start by addressing
the stereotypes that are turning off not
only women but anyone else who falls
outside of the narrow definition we have
of what it means to be a techie to other
women out there please don't make the
mistake of believing you're the only one
struggling with these feelings ask for
help when you need it get past with
you're stuck on and I guarantee one day
you'll be that person for someone else
to those of you in the majority we need
your help to understand that even under
the near of confidence a person that you
could reach out to is struggling against
an invisible current that they may not
even know is there know that even your
simple nudge of encouragement can make
all the difference that's how I got past
my wall and finally to everyone else all
I ask is this be more mindful of the
stereotypes that you unintentionally
propagate think about it really what it
really means when you tell someone of
course you're going to get into that
program you're a woman or what you're
really saying when you tell someone you
don't look like an engineer the power of
stereotype comes from repetition over
and over again until the idea is
ingrained within our culture which means
we're all guilty of contributing to the
problem to quote from a fellow TED
speaker the problem with our stereotypes
around computer scientists it's not that
they're wrong it's just that they're
incomplete there's space here for
mathletes and athletes cake bakers and
robot makers let's start by widening our
definition of what it means to be a
computer scientist so the next time you
close your eyes you can imagine Barbie
coding alongside Stephan and Brian and
then together we can all build a future
in which we can live long and prosper
[Applause]
[Music]